Iran's neighbors in the Middle East are
reacting to the tankers attacks in
different ways Charlie d'Agata is in the
United Arab Emirates with the regional
response good morning well the United
States is trying to ramp up
international support but the case
against Iran is not a slam dunk here
officials here in the UAE have been
careful not to directly name-check Iran
instead saying the attacks of the work
of an unnamed state actor Iran's
regional archrival Saudi Arabia has
taken a far more aggressive approach
releasing video of Saudi military
aircraft in u.s. fighter jets in
formation conducting exercises over the
Persian Gulf in a clear show of force
and a message aimed directly at Iran the
Saudi Crown Prince says flat-out accused
Iran in its proxies of being behind the
attacks now both of those tankers are
now just off the coast here in Fujairah
but we're being kept well away from them
in fact we've been told in no uncertain
terms that taking a boat out and doing
filming of any description is strictly
forbidden that just underlines the
extreme sensitivities here Anthony
Charlie d'Agata thanks